Larsa are we getting it popping at
bravocon we are definitely getting it
popping at bravocon this is my first
time at bravocon and I am obsessed
they're gonna have to invite me every
year because I just love this so much
it's been such a great experience I love
seeing all the different franchises and
I love the camaraderie of all the girls
so it's really been fun for me well I
think they're going to keep inviting you
back as long as Miami's around and we're
going to be around so no just kidding no
you are I got my eyes on the trailer
early
did yes it is oh yeah I don't know I
haven't even seen it we need to as a
group learn how to put each other up on
pillars when they go lower you go higher
you know what I mean like no no don't
look at me like that you tell me what to
do okay you gotta respect me period no
where are you
well Gertie tries to advise you to go
high when others go low and you say well
I'm old school so I feel like I show
love but if you don't reciprocate the
love then I go up down all the way
around with my punches
so give me a tease for the season what
can we expect from your kind of personal
story and where you float within the
group are you and Adriana in a better
place than we left Jenna worst place
um I feel like you'll have to watch and
see but I do feel like for me personally
I think it's about like the journey and
the growth and I've really been working
on my relationships with my friends and
just being a better person and a better
human and I feel like that's you know
that's what I work on these days but did
you bond with anyone in particular this
season
um I feel like I bonded with all the
women you know I feel like Marisol and I
are really close now you know Lexie have
always been close to to I love Lisa Lisa
you know went through her crazy
situation and I feel like I was really
there for her as a friend
so I do feel like you know it's all
about relationships yeah I you went
through a very different end of a
marriage a more amicable end of a
marriage so what was it like to walk
your friend through that because the
trailer very much is the Lisa show my
husband built the perfect wife and
and built the perfect life
blink of an eye my life changed
my best friend losing my husband to
another woman I mean I I do feel like a
lot of relationships you know there's a
lot of breakups but it's basically about
how you handle it and I just feel bad
that their breakup was so like toxic at
the end and so you know I just I know
different relationships are you know
they're hard when you break up people
are hurt it's dark it's not happy but I
do feel like there is light at the end
of the tunnel and I just keep reminding
Lisa that and your relationships are the
ones the media invents make a lot of
headlines what did you make of all that
about Michael Jordan's son and you you
know you've said that you're friends but
it keeps popping up people say you're
dating
I have a lot of friends I mean I'm very
social I was married for 23 years like
this is the time for me to really like
hone in all my relationships so that's
kind of what I'm doing will we see you
date on the new season
I did a little bit on the new season
yeah do any of the women set you up
would you want them to no I feel like my
type is a bit different than the other
girls types yeah yeah yeah you you told
me you're like a boss I like a boss but
I like a I like a really like I like a
sweetheart I like a boss but like
someone that's really sweet and like
caring too okay so you you almost you're
like a hard shell candy like hard on the
outside soft on the inside inside yes
yeah there we go that's that's what I
love
[Music]